Here's the completed app for
looking at activities.
I've started to show all the possible
activities it detects and
you can see that it has a percentage for
each one.
For example, when I was testing this
earlier, it determined there was a 45%
chance I was on foot, 45% chance
walking, 25% in a vehicle, etc.
Now it can't be 100% sure for
some activities, so
it's up to you as a developer
to figure out what works best.
When you start a car for example,
you're driving really slowly.
And it might think you're biking or
running for example.
This app will just show you how to get
the data, its up to you to figure out
how to use it in the best
possible way for your app.
You're going to build this from scratch.